The Warlords of the Sea are one of the strongest
groups of pirates in One Piece. Some of them
are nearly as powerful as the Emperors and
some simply have ridiculously over-powered
devil fruits. Yet none of them has ever
gone on to become king of the pirates,
so far at least. But what would happen if Luffy
had eaten their crazy devil fruits instead?
And even though it would obviously be a ton of fun
to think about Luffy having Mihawk’s sword skills,
since we’re talking about devil fruits
specifically for this video the focus
will be on Crocodile’s absurdly powerful Sand
fruit, Gecko Moria’s sinister Shadow fruit,
Doflamingo’s manipulative String fruit, and
Bartholemew Kuma’s unbelievably overpowered
Paw fruit. The pirate Empress Boa Hancock
was also one of the original warlords,
but her fruit makes absolutely no sense for
Luffy, so we aren’t going to include it.
So we begin in Luffy’s childhood, where kid Luffy
is eying not one but five treasure boxes that
Shanks’ crew has left lying around the bar. One
of these contains Luffy’s original devil fruit,
and the others have the Warlord’s devil fruits
that we’ll assume that somehow Shanks stole. So
the always hungry Luffy sneakily steals a treasure
chest and takes a bite of this weird looking fruit
inside. And as he’s munching away, Shanks and
the crew go absolutely bonkers. Shanks grabs his
arm and instantly a little shadow clone of Luffy
comes up from the floor to slap away Shanks’ hand.
May I now introduce, Shadow Luffy.
And before we get into all of the surprisingly
crazy changes this would have on the story,
let’s talk for a second about devil fruits
and personalities. In a previous video,
I explained how there is a pretty strong theory
that devil fruits contain a will of their own,
and when someone eats a devil fruit then the
fruit’s will can affect the person who ate it.
For example, Gecko Moria, the original user of
the Shadow fruit, is pretty damn lazy and uses
other people’s shadows to do his dirty work.
But was this Moria just utilizing his fruit or
was the nature of the shadow fruit encouraging
him to use the powers in this way? Similarly,
Doflamingo’s string fruit can literally make
people into puppets, so was it just the perfect
fruit for Doflamingo or did the fruit encourage
him to become an evil, underground puppet master?
And we even see a bit of this with
Luffy during his fight with Kaido,
where Luffy is laughing uncontrollably after
awakening his original devil fruit powers.
So because Luffy is eating a different devil
fruit, his personality may change slightly. He may
not be the guy who ALWAYS bounces back from defeat
because that was the main characteristic of his
original devil fruit. And someone like Ace would
probably get his original devil fruit instead.
And with that in mind, let’s dive right into
the shady powers of the Shadow Fruit. Basically,
this fruit allows you to manipulate shadows,
both your own and other people’s. On the zombie
island Thriller Bark, we learned that Moria
can take shadows from other people and then
use them to bring corpses back to life or to
massively increase his own strength. Also,
his own shadow basically became
a second version of himself that
can act independently. So this is
a seriously powerful devil fruit.
However for Luffy, this fruit is THE ABSOLUTE
WORST match out of these four warlord fruits. The
other fruit fit his personality way better, as we
will see later in the video, but this one is going
to present major obstacles for Luffy. And that’s
because the downside of taking someone’s shadow is
that they will die if they go in sunlight. So this
leaves us with two options. First is that Luffy
doesn’t ever take someone else’s shadow, meaning
he doesn’t use the fruit’s main power. Or second
is that his personality is completely changed
by the devil fruit. In this case, Shadow Luffy
would no longer care about other people dying, so
he is totally fine stealing shadows from anyone
he meets. But while this didn’t bother Moria, I
simply cannot imagine Luffy taking shadows from
innocent people and then just leaving them to
die or hide in the dark the rest of their lives.
So if he isn’t going to steal shadows,
that basically leaves Luffy with just his
own shadow to manipulate. Which is still
pretty badass because it is basically an
unkillable copy of yourself. So let’s see
how far Luffy can go with these powers.
After training for ten years, I think Luffy
would definitely learn how to use his shadow
clone incredibly well. He could make it appear,
block attacks, fight for him, and even seamlessly
swap places with his shadow. So while I don’t
think he would have any problem in the East Blue,
the real challenge comes in Alabasta against
the Warlord Crocodile. As we already mentioned,
Crocodile has the sand devil fruit which turns
his body into sand. And just like any Logia this
means that he is virtually untouchable unless
someone uses haki or discovers their elemental
weakness. And in the original story, Luffy
was only able to defeat him by getting the
sand wet with blood and water. And even then
Luffy suffered two crushing defeats twice and
only lived because of a combination of
luck, his allies, and his rubbed body.
However, Shadow Luffy would
have none of these advantages,
and would even be much less skilled at combat.
Luffy’s body is normal and cannot stretch,
so he is basically just a normal fighter with
his shadow clone. But since he cannot use haki
yet and his body wouldn’t be as durable, I do
not think Luffy would survive this encounter.
But even if he did survive, he would definitely
lose to another strong fighter in the Grand Line.
So goodbye Shadow Luffy.
And if this version of Luffy could not even
make it past the first half of the Grand Line,
will any of these new devil fruits
be strong enough for Luffy to become
pirate king? Some of these upcoming
storylines are absolutely insane.
Because while the Shadow fruit
was a truly awful match for Luffy,
this next one will allow him
to unleash his full power.
So Reset. Back to chapter 1. Only this
time hungry kid Luffy eats this devil
fruit. Shanks grabs his arm, and instantly a
razor-sharp string pops out and cuts Shanks’
hand. Looks like this time in the devil
fruit lottery, Luffy won the string fruit.
And originally this fruit was
eaten by Donquixote Doflamingo,
the Warlord who conquered the kingdom of
Alabasta. This fruit allows you to produce
and control an infinite amount of string
which can be used to make life-like clones,
attach his string to other people to make them his
puppets, and even stitch together internal wounds.
So this fruit is super versatile and is a perfect
fit for Luffy’s creativity. So he will surely
take advantage of the ten years training
to become an expert at using his strings.
But since Doffy was a cold-hearted monster,
we have to wonder if the fruit would make
Luffy become more manipulative as well. Would
Luffy still gather such a loyal crew? Well,
I think so because even Doflamingo was fiercely
loyal to his core crew. But he was totally fine
using other people. And while I don’t think Luffy
will follow completely in Doflamingo’s footsteps,
there are plenty of ways for him to use the
strings without controlling innocent people.
And compared to Luffy’s base rubber form,
String Luffy is arguably much stronger. He
can fly like spider man, fire string bullets,
and even cut with his sharp string. So I think
Luffy would have an even easier time in
the East Blue than in the original story.
But moving ahead to the first major challenge,
Crocodile. Luffy would again have a harder time
discovering the secret of Logia fruit weaknesses.
Since most of String Luffy’s attacks come from a
distance, he will have a harder time learning that
his blood or water can allow him to actually hurt
the Sand fruit user. But because Luffy can fly
around and he doesn’t have to physically punch,
he would probably survive longer during the
fight, and eventually learn the secret to defeat
Crocodile. Or maybe he traps Crocodile in a super
compact ball of string and dumps him in the ocean.
However, the lightning fruit user Enel is
on a completely different level. Because
Luffy does not have his natural rubber
immunity, and he doesn’t yet have haki,
the Lightning fruit user would probably destroy
Luffy. However, it is also possible that String
Luffy is so smart at using his devil fruit that he
could make giant string conductors to channel the
lightning away from himself. He still wouldn’t
be able to hit Enel, unless he uses Sea Stone,
so either way this is going to be very difficult
and probably lead to Luffy’s defeat. On the other
hand, maybe String Luffy is smarter about
escaping and simply runs away to survive.
But let’s assume he did win, or he just escaped.
Then he would still probably need to be saved
after losing to Aokiji. But then Water 7 and Enies
Lobby would be a breeze. Since he can fly around,
I think he has a much easier time saving Robin
and defeating CP9. Because one of the biggest
advantages of this fruit is that he can attack
from a distance, so he doesn’t need to even be
close to deal insane amounts of damage to this
leopard man. And even if Robin did get captured,
Luffy could make his own version of the birdcage
to make sure she wasn’t taken away. Plus Luffy
could also make keys out of string to unlock
her handcuffs, making her rescue much simpler.
And Moria would be a joke to fight,
especially because Luffy can even
control the shadow zombies like puppets.
And I don’t see any real
changes to Sabaody either,
but Impel down would be completely different.
Luffy would still need help sneaking in,
but then Luffy can travel between levels super
easily. He could also slice open prison bars,
so it is highly likely that he could save his
brother before Ace is taken to Marineford.
Luffy’s fight with this venomous warden
would also be WAY easier. Attacking from
a distance means that Luffy can easily avoid
the warden’s deadly poisons and I think he
has a strong chance of winning this fight.
Similarly, in his encounter with Blackbeard,
Luffy could slash the darkness man before
he has a chance to enact his evil plan.
But let’s say that maybe Luffy got caught in a
cloud of poison gas and Ace was still taken to
Marineford. Now although Luffy might be able to
get to Ace more easily during this epic battle,
I still think he would be overwhelmed by the
monstrously strong fighters on the battlefield.
So this leads us to the time skip and once Luffy
learns Haki EVERYTHING CHANGES. After training
for two years, Luffy is now a master with his
haki-coated strings and can take on anyone.
The fishman Hoady and the evil scientist Caesar
would be no problem. There would be no conflict
in Dressrosa since Doflamingo doesn’t have his
string fruit and never took over the country.
Of course, Big Mom and Kaido would still be
major obstacles, but these clashes are more
about superior haki than devil fruit powers,
so I think Luffy would still come out on top
just like in the main story, leaving Luffy
well on his way to becoming pirate king.
So with one devil fruit turning out very very bad,
and one working perfectly for
Luffy to continue on his journey,
what will happen to Luffy’s journey when he gets
the two most powerful devil fruits on this list?
Now let’s cycle back to chapter one again,
where Luffy has stolen this devil fruit and
takes a giant bite. Alarmed, Shanks grabs
Luffy’s arm and POOF, it explodes into a
cloud of sand. Shanks jaw drops, and
Luffy dissolves into a pile of sand.
But now armed with the same fruit that defeated
Shadow Luffy, let’s see how far Sand Luffy can
go. And it might actually surprise with some
of the new challenges he has to overcome
And since this is a Logia fruit which
turns Luffy’s entire body into sand,
it is arguably the strongest of the four devil
fruits in this video. Just like any other Logia,
he cannot be hit by anyone who doesn’t know
haki. He can transform into a cloud of sand,
dry things out with touch, and create
sharp blades of sand to attack opponents.
However, as we discussed earlier all Logia’s
have some elemental weakness and this fruit
has the biggest one in the whole story.
Water. If Sand Luffy gets wet from water
or blood or some other liquid, he immediately
loses his invincibility. And unfortunately
for Sand Luffy, water just happens to
be literally everywhere in this world.
But East Blue would still be a breeze, except
maybe if this fishman was constantly wet. There
is a debate about Sand Luffy versus the Smoke
Logia fruit user, Smoker, but with his body
being literally sand Luffy wouldn’t have even
been captured in Logue Town in the first place.
And even if Crocodile somehow managed to take
over Alabasta without his sand powers, this desert
kingdom is literally the best place for Luffy to
fight, so Luffy would defeat Crocodile easily.
But the bigger question is how will Sand
Luffy do against other overpowered Logia’s
like Enel and the marine admirals?
And this becomes highly dependent
on matchups. So let’s analyze
these fights for just a minute.
Against Enel, Sand is actually a
very poor conductor of electricity,
so while Luffy may not be completely unaffected
by lightning like he was with his rubber body,
he would still have a strong chance since
all lightning would do is heat up the sand.
But while Luffy might do well in Skypiea, once he
comes down to the sea, he would face his ABSOLUTE
WORST matchup in the story against the Ice
Logia user Aokiji. Since Aokiji would have a
near constant source of melting ice and he knows
haki there is ZERO CHANCE Luffy would win this
fight. And Aokiji would demand Luffy subscribe to
the channel for more of these What ifs… or else.
And then the story progresses pretty
much the same through the time skip,
when Luffy would learn haki. This makes the
post-time skip even easier since he can now
pretty easily fight other Logia users. But ALL
THIS CHANGES when we reach the most fearsome
opponents: Big Mom and Kaido. And as we’ve
already discussed, these battles are intense
clashes of supreme haki. And surely, most
definitely, Sand Luffy would stand NO CHANCE.
And before you go crazy in the comments,
let me explain. In chapter 886,
we are told in a flashback that haki
blooms most during intense battle. But
since Sand Luffy’s logia powers gave him a
much easier time during the post time skip,
he hasn’t had to endure the same struggles which
allowed him to truly master haki. And this comes
back to bite him later on, as Kaido
and Big Mom would absolutely destroy
him and his underdeveloped haki,
bringing an end to Sand Luffy.
So with three fruits down and one
to go, this brings us to the final,
and most life-changing fruit in this video.
Back in the bar, Luffy takes a bite of this
mysterious fruit. Shanks loses his mind and grabs
him, staring at the strange paw pads on Luffy’s
hands. But then Luffy freaks out and a huge
explosion of air demolishes the entire building.
Whoops.
And this begins the most interesting
part of this What If scenario. You see,
the Paw fruit was one of my Top 5 most
overpowered devil fruits in a recent video,
and its powers are truly mind-blogging. It was
used by the former Warlord Bartholemew Kuma and
its powers allow you to repel anything. This means
that any kind of attack can be easily blocked.
But even crazier is that you can repel
things like air to make a compression bomb,
or you can push yourself so fast that you
can literally travel across the world.
But the most insane part of this
fruit is that it can even repel
intangible concepts like pain or
memories from a person’s body.
Now can you imagine Luffy learning to
control this fruit and all the wild,
imaginative things that he could do with it? The
potential for Luffy and this fruit are limitless.
Could he push pain out of himself to heal?
Could he push hunger out of himself to make
it so that he is never hungry? Or how about
his stupidity? Could that make him smarter?
And after ten years of training, Luffy
wouldn’t even need a ship. He can simply
push himself across the sea to wherever he wants
to go. And while I don’t think Luffy will be a
master of this just yet, because he probably
wouldn’t know the world’s geography too well,
he should be able to do small pushes to
keep him in the air and go between islands.
But one of the most interesting questions
with this fruit is would Paw Luffy even
gather a crew? For example, while Kuma was
a founding member of the Revolutionary army,
we almost always see him by himself. Was
this just Kuma’s personality or was it
something about the fruit that naturally
repelled other people? And if we apply
that same idea to Luffy, would this fruit
make him less willing to gather a crew?
But for now, let’s assume that Paw Luffy
still meets Zoro and Nami. But things
completely change once they steal the map
of the grand line from this clown. You see,
Paw Luffy is super excited about the Grand
Line. And before Nami can talk him out of it,
Luffy launches the three of them straight
to the entrance to the Grand Line, Reverse
Mountain. But as they’re hanging in the air,
Nami is shouting at Luffy, demanding that he
take them back. Meanwhile, Luffy and Zoro argue
about which direction to take. And of course,
knowing these two, instead of entering the
much safer starting point of the Grand Line,
they take a completely wrong turn and end up near
the end of the Grand Line, at Egghead Island.
And this wrong turn nearly spells the end
of this massively unprepared crew. First,
they land at the secret laboratory of the
genius scientist Dr. Vegapunk. And of course,
Vegapunk is incredibly interested in Paw Luffy’s
powers. Because we recently learned that Kuma used
the fruit to aid Vegapunk’s research. But Luffy
has no interest in staying to do some science,
so he launches the group across the
sea straight onto this evil looking
skull dome. And this, of course, is the
home of the Emperor of the Sea, Kaido.
And it’s at this point, Nami is seriously
regretting ever joining Paw Luffy. But while
sneaking around the island, they meet Yamato, the
child or Kaido, who has been trapped on the island
by her father. And of course Yamato knows exactly
who Luffy is, since they met with Ace a few years
ago, and they are desperate to go out to sea
with the trio. So Luffy uses his Paw powers
to push off their handcuffs just as Kaido finds
them. And he is furious that these random pirates
have invaded his castle. He charges up a full
dragon blast breath. Nami is screaming with fear,
but Luffy grabs them all and pushes them out
to safety, all the way back to the East Blue.
And after landing, the crew is exhausted. But
Luffy and Yamato think it was all hilarious
while Nami is furious and Zoro just wants some
booze. But it’s at this point that Nami beats
into Luffy’s head that they can’t just skip
ahead because there are people way too powerful
for them. So Luffy decides to actually do things
right, and build a proper crew with a real ship.
And with Yamato along for the ride,
this changes everything since they is
nearly as strong as Kaido already. So the
East Blue is pathetically easy for them,
and they enter the Grand Line full of confidence.
But Yamato is not just a strong fighter.
They also know all about haki, so they are
able to teach the crew the basics. And this
allows the crew to easily take out Crocodile,
Enel, and even give Aokiji a difficult fight.
And since this version of Luffy uses the Paw
fruit instead of Kuma, this means the crew
would not be separated at Sabaody. They
would still need to escape from Kizaru,
but with Rayleigh’s help I think they
would be able to all get away together.
And this brings us to Marineford, where the buffed
up version of the crew comes ever so close to
saving Ace. But the combined force of the marines
is just too much, and Ace eventually is killed.
Which brings us to the time-skip. Now
it’s possible the crew could go on ahead
to Fishman Island right away since they are
all together, but I think the crushing defeat
would mean they still decide to wait and train
for a bit before heading into the New World.
But when they do enter the
New World after the time skip,
they have even more motivation to take down
Kaido because Yamato would definitely tell
them all about the situation on Wano.
She might even recognize these two
samurai right away and the Straw Hats would
definitely want to help save their country.
And the crew would pretty
easily move through Dressrosa,
which brings us to the Emperor’s saga. And
this part of Paw Luffy’s story is incredibly
difficult to speculate about because the
most important part of fighting the Yonko
is having ridiculously strong haki. But we
don’t exactly know how haki interacts with
Luffy’s devil fruit. So unless Luffy becomes
an absolute powerhouse with his devil fruit,
he might struggle with some of the strongest
fighters like Kaido and Big Mom. Or he might
just have to learn to fight with his bare hands
and feet in order to really use his haki powers.
On the other hand, the limits of this fruit
are still unknown. Luffy could become the most
overpowered devil fruit user and simply defeat
everyone with his Paw fruit. For example, could
he push the soul out of big mom’s homies? Or could
he push a devil fruit power out of someone like
Kaido, making him lose all of his dragon powers?
Seriously, this fruit is wild and until we know
more about it, it is hard to say how Luffy would
fare against the strongest fighters in the story.
But the biggest question for all of these devil
fruits is if Luffy would still become the pirate
king. Shadow Luffy would definitely fail,
and I think Sand Luffy would as well. But
String Luffy and Paw Luffy definitely have
a chance to pursue the ultimate dream. But
one thing that will be the same no matter what
fruit Luffy has, are Luffy’s rivals. Blackbeard
and Shanks are the ultimate powers standing
in his way, and if you want to see what would
happen if Luffy fought Blackbeard and Shanks
for the One Piece, you can click right here.
Shanks for watching.